all right let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
all right number one you've probably
heard this by now but let's play it
again anyway just for old times sake
what you all know but most people don't
know unlike the african-american
community with notable exceptions
the latino community is an incredibly
diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
yes there is joe biden suggesting for
a very inconceivable reason
that black people are a monolith and
they all think exactly the same
now he posted a statement last night
clarifying those remarks but the
clarification doesn't really clarify
anything this is what he says
earlier today i made some comments about
diversity in the african-american and
latino communities that i want to
clarify
in no way did i suggest or did i mean to
suggest
that the african-american community is a
monolith not by identity
not not on issues not at all throughout
my career i have witnessed the diversity
of thought background and sentiment
within the african-american community
it's this diversity that makes our
workplaces communities and country a
better place my commitment to you is
this i will always listen i will never
stop fighting for the african-american
community and i will never stop fighting
for a more equitable future
see that's not really a clarification
because he didn't explain just exactly
what he was trying to say with his
original comment that's what a cl
clarification clarifies it makes clear
what was said before
um but it doesn't that doesn't do it
because what he said in the original
comment
was unambiguous he straight up said that
the black community is not diverse he
was he was he was claiming that all
black people think alike
this is not the first time he said that
remember
famously he said that if you don't vote
for him you ain't black
okay this is a common theme that he goes
back to
and it need it doesn't even need to be
said but i'll say it anyway just
imagine the reaction if donald trump
said
any of that okay donald trump is
constantly accused of saying racist
things
uh i can't think of an example of
something that that donald trump has
actually said publicly is confirmed to
have said
that approaches uh
just these two examples in terms of
racism i i can't think of anything that
gets near it
speaking of donald trump by the way um
president trump
came out yesterday also with an attack
on biden
that i thought was pretty notable let's
let's listen to that
no religion know anything hurt the bible
hurt
god he's against god he's against guns
he's against energy our kind of energy
i just love the pause there hurt the
bible
hurt god
he's gonna hurt god he's gonna kick
god in the shins and stomp on his foot
hurting god uh i
i i see this i you know i think about
yesterday
where you had biden out there saying
that black people all think the same
and then trump's saying that biden's
trying to hurt god and i see that and i
i get really sad and i'll tell you why i
get sad because i i think
of what we're missing by not having a
real campaign season because this isn't
a real campaign season we're not we're
probably
we're almost certainly not gonna have
debates they're not doing uh campaign
speeches they're not out and about you
know doing all of that
uh especially biden is not so it's not a
real campaign can you imagine though
if if we had a real campaign season with
these two
how hilarious it would be it's already
pretty funny
even without it but if if these guys
were out in front of people every day
giving speeches speaking live
and constantly upping the ante and
throwing accusations at each other
that would be spectacular and we are
missing that
i think what we saw yesterday was just a
shadow of what could have been it was a
it's a little
morsel of what could have been had we
if we had a real campaign season um
i mean you could always argue of course
that it's not actually funny at all
because this is the future of our
country at stake but
we're we are very much in a laugh or cry
situation
and so uh sometimes i choose to laugh
because crying on camera would be
rather unseemly number two hundreds of
teachers gathered in new york yesterday
to protest
plans to reopen let's take a look at
that scene
[Music]
yes they were carrying a coffin there
was also a guillotine
coffins and guillotines is is what they
brought
now if it were up to me we would just
fire all of these
pathetic useless cowards
you're marching through the street with
a coffin weeping
because you have to go back to work
after five months
my god you pitiful clowns
and you know something i guarantee that
every single one of those people
every single one they've all been to
target
they've all been to fast food
drive-throughs
many other businesses they've ordered
amazon pickup
you know something tells me i i don't
think they've been living
uh by you know self-sustaining gardening
and
and maybe going for hunts in the woods i
i don't think that's how
i think they've probably been living a
relatively normal life
as much as possible so the point is they
have no problem
with those employees being back at work
the target cashier they got no problem
with her being working
they have no problem with sending the
target employees to the guillotine by
their own logic
they're fine with that but them they
have to work
them oh no they're teachers you can't
make them work they
they're they're these are hallowed
sainted heroes
hallowed sainted heroes that don't want
to go to work and uh and and provide an
education because they're scared
real heroic so i guess i should issue my
own clarification i said that they the
teachers were protesting reopening
now they weren't protesting reopening
anything but schools they're fine with
everything else being open
and everybody else working just not them
because they're special
number three the actress maddie ziegler
who i've never
heard of but apparently well she's an
actress
she has now apologized for racially
insensitive videos that she made
and she said in her apology um quote i
know some of you are hurt and may not
accept my apology
and then she also said she was uh
ashamed and uh truly sorry
and she goes on apologies a lengthy
statement apologizing
and this is why i should probably
mention that she's apologizing
for supposedly racist videos that she
made
when she was nine years old nine
she is 17 now so that was eight years
ago at the age of nine
she made quote racially insensitive
videos and now has been forced to
apologize
all i'm going to say about that is if
you
as an adult have ever been hurt
by insensitive comments from a
nine-year-old
then you need to consult a psychologist
about your undiagnosed mental illnesses
assuming now maybe maddie z i don't know
anything about this maybe she
just on her own decided to come out an
apology if so then then fine but if this
was precipitated
by any sort of pressure from anybody who
had their
feelings hurt by eight videos from eight
years ago of a nine-year-old
then uh yes i i would say seek seek
psychological care
okay uh number four a few days ago i
showed you that picture of jerry falwell
jr
liberty university president on a yacht
with his pants unzipped and his shirt
pulled up
standing with a woman who had her pants
unzipped and had her shirt pulled up
and he he appeared to be holding an
alcoholic beverage
and um and it all sort of appears to be
not exactly the kind of thing that the
president of a conservative christian
school
would uh want to especially conserve a
christian school that expels kids for
drinking and acting just like is
portrayed in that photo
not the kind of thing he'd want to post
on social media but he did post it and
then he took it down but of course it
was too late
now a couple days later this clip
but i'll play for you in a second
supposedly of jerry falwell jr
calling into a morning radio show and
explaining himself started making the
rounds
and i swear to you i heard this thing
and i really assumed right away
that it was fake that it was some kind
of morning radio you know
morning zoo gag or something or somebody
calling in pretending to be falwell
but apparently according to politico and
other outlets this is real this is
really falwell
and this is actually from a news talk
radio radio show in lynchburg virginia
where
liberty university is located and it's
also a longer interview where he talks
about other random things so yes this
appears to be
actually real this is actually falwell
jr calling in
and this is what he has to say listen to
this what was up with that picture on
instagram
you know it was weird because she could
she was she's pregnant so she couldn't
get her
she couldn't get her pants dipped and i
was like
trying to like my i had a pair of jeans
that i haven't worn in a long time
so i couldn't get mine zipped either
and so i just put my belly i just put my
belly out like hers
and it was just um she's my wife's
assistant
and she's a sweetheart and i should
never
put up embarrassed her because
um anyway i i've apologized to everybody
and i promised my kids i'm going to try
to be better i'm going to try to be a
good boy from here on out okay he he
sounds
extremely intoxicated to me is it just
me or or
does he not sound very drunk in that
on a weekday morning calling into a
radio show
he sounds very drunk to me i don't know
if he is
i can't say that but he really sounds it
to me
i mean i'm gonna be a good boy
this is a 58 year old president
of the most prominent supposedly
conservative christian school in america
after that photo he calls in a few days
later
i'm gonna be a good boy
i couldn't get my pants zipped up that
this is how he responds and this again
is the president of a christian
university
it's embarrassing and they have a board
of trustees at liberty university they
need to dump this guy they need to get
rid of him because he's an embarrassment
to the school
and to the christian faith and always
has been to be honest with you
uh and he's just a disgrace and he needs
to go all right number five
stan van gundy former nba coach current
nba announcer
uh posted this to twitter trying to
justify speaking of a disgrace the nba
submission to china
uh and their silence in the face of
chinese atrocities
this is what he said he said we
committed genus we committed genocide
against native americans
we have enslaved lynched segregated and
incarcerated blacks over 400 years
women couldn't vote for 140 years using
abuses elsewhere to try to distract from
our own poor record on human rights
is dishonest now of course the irony
here is that he is
he's saying others are using abuses
elsewhere to distract from things
happening
he's using abuses from hundreds of years
ago to distract from
abuses that are happening right now
today
um in in china but
all i really wanted to say here is you
know he says we committed genocide
against native americans we've enslaved
and lynched
uh black people well
what i'd say to stan van gundy is listen
stan
uh if you have committed those crimes
then you need to turn yourself into the
authorities immediately i
i appreciate you confessing to it and
accepting some accountability but the
real accountability for you as some i
mean you're confessing here you've said
that you're something we that includes
yourself so you've said that you have
committed genocide
and you've enslaved and lynched people
uh
you you need to contact the fbi and turn
yourself in immediately
now me personally i've never done any of
those things
i haven't done anything close to any of
those things
nobody in my family has even done any of
those things
so i am 100 innocent of all of those
crimes
i don't know who the we is here it
certainly isn't me
so you're you're being a little bit uh
you so there's some you're being vague
here i'm not exactly sure
but but whoever it is whoever your
accomplices are in this i
you all need to turn yourselves in and
face justice
um so that's that's all
that's all i can say about that that is
a that is a stunning
admission and confession from stan van
gundy i'm surprised it's not getting
more
more coverage thank you for tuning in to
the daily wire one of the fastest
growing conservative media outlets in
the entire country if you enjoyed this
video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content